[Music]
we
are back but before we begin let's pay
our respects to mix mayfield who
perished tragically last week in a
refinery accident
hey everyone i want to start this video
by apologizing over the lack of
mandalorian videos lately as some of you
may or may not know youtube isn't my
full-time job and sometimes other work
gets in the way but i'm hoping if i have
time
i can still get some videos out because
as the great jeff goldblum says
life uh finds a way but enough chitchat
we have an
action-packed episode of the mandaloria
to get to in what's the second last
episode of the season before i'm put
back in cryo-sleep for season
3. and holy crap i might have to create
an entirely new channel just dedicated
to star wars with all the new show
announcements at yesterday's disney's
investors day
shut up and take my money i hope you're
all not getting grogu withdrawal because
this is the first episode of 15 that has
yet to feature
our adorable little green guy but rest
assured he'll be making an appearance
next episode as mando has successfully
received the coordinates for moff
gideon's ship
and if his little hologram speech at the
end is any indication
shit's about to go down maybe we'll even
see more force powers from grogu kind of
like what we saw at the end of chapter
14
and a surprise appearance by whomever he
was communicating with when he went into
his deep meditation
i also wouldn't be surprised if the
final episode briefly introduces us to
grand admiral thrawn who was teased at
in chapter 13.
where is grand admiral thrawn now
chapter 15 is directed by rick famous
who also directed chapter 6 the prisoner
starring bill burr's mayfield so it's
good they brought him back to kind of
bridge mayfield's character
and we start right at the carthon chop
fields this is a new republic hard labor
camp where mayfield has been sentenced
for 50 years
you'll remember that in chapter 6 he was
apprehended by the new republic
all a result of the mandalorian and this
scrap metal yard is filled with torn up
tie fighters and other material
you'll even see these repurposed at80s
hauling pieces in the background
kind of like that atat we saw pulling
wreckage out of the port of trask in
chapter 11.
these things sure have come in handy
post-fall of the empire
in walks cara dune who mando tasked with
tracking down mayfailed one of a handful
of people who could potentially gain
access to an
internal imperial terminal that's
because mayfield used to be an imperial
sharpshooter and his clearances and
protocols are likely still intact dune
and now a marshal for the new republic
is able to spring mayfield from his life
of hard labor
and in return for helping them gets a
quote change of scenery
i don't know seems like a pretty good
deal to me he's got this lindsay lohan
style ankle bracelet which is taken off
and we even get to see these new
republic droids the same ones from the
prison ship in chapter 6
intimidate him with an electric baton
you'll also notice
this large ship here which looks exactly
like one of the prison transport ships
in chapter 6
probably unloading a fresh batch of
prisoners
mayfield's taken to boba fett's ship the
slave 1 which we saw last episode and
was previously helmed by boba's
father jango in attack of the clones and
it looks like boba has had some time to
pimp out his now returned armor which if
we go back
looked like it had seen better days
mayfield says
you know for a second i thought you're
this other guy referring to mando but
unfortunately for him amando's here with
grogu captured by moff gideon last
episode mando needs to locate the
imperial cruiser he was taken to
and the only way to do that is through
an imperial terminal
so the crew comprised of mando boba kara
dune fenexchant and
mayfield set out to the mining planet of
morack we even get to see a bit of how
the inside of the slave 1 works
which seems to operate in such a way
where the passengers remain upright
while the ship itself
rotates prior to this the only inside of
the ship we ever really got to see was
the cockpit in attack of the clones
a scan of the planet uncovers a mining
refinery where an extremely volatile
mineral called rhidonium is refined
problem is they just can't get down into
the base and sneak into it it's covered
with anti-aircraft and platoon security
forces
so they'll need to be quiet the base is
operated by what mayfeld calls remnant
these are the imperial forces that
remained after the fall of the galactic
empire
mainly in the outer reaches of the
galaxy specifically these are the isb
forces or the imperial security bureau
largely in charge of law enforcement and
ensuring the loyalty of its citizens to
the empire with the amount of security
and scanners only mando and mayfield
could possibly get in without alerting
the authorities
cara boba and fennec are all wanted by
the isb
so they commandeered what's known as a
juggernaut these
giant mining trucks a variant of which
we saw in rogue one mayfeld and mando
switch into
transport armor in order to keep up the
ruse mando even hands over his precious
best car armor to kara for safe keeping
this is one of the few moments we've
seen mando not in his regular armor
while riding the juggernaut they come
across the wreckages of other transport
vehicles it's likely this wreckage was
caused by local pirates who will see
attempt to take over the vehicle
and thermal detonate the highly volatile
rhidonium the controls of the juggernaut
are even fitted with stability meters
which
track how stable the minerals are as
they navigate the treacherous terrain
even going dangerously close to the
point of no return as they're attacked
by the pirates
along the way they pass a local village
as children look at them with disdain
perhaps this child mando locks eyes with
reminds him of himself as a
child left abandoned by war as mayfield
says of the people here
empire new republic it's all the same to
these people
invaders on their land is all we are he
even brings up this notion of choice
you have these two sides the empire and
the new republic but really what
choice do you have on what side you're
on you're brought up and you're gonna
fit whatever role was given to you
look i'm just saying we're all the same
everybody's got their lines they don't
cross until things get messy and
mayfield even begins to chip away at
mando's belief in the mandalorian code
specifically of him not taking off his
helmet what's the deal
is it because he's not allowed to show
his face to others or is it because he
must always have his helmet on
in chapter 11 bo katan tells mando that
she's mandalorian yet doesn't always
wear her helmet
you do not cover your face you are not
mandalorian part of mando's journey this
season is discovering what it means to
be mandalorian
and questioning the way he's been
brought up but he's
stubborn there is only one way the way
of the mandalore
these conversations with mayfield
bokoten and even ahsoka are all meant to
slowly chip away at mando's preconceived
notions of what it means to be
mandalorian and this is all part of his
character arc
while on their way to the refinery
they're attacked by a group of pirates
who in
any other episode would be perceived as
freedom fighters but because the
perspective of this episode is from the
side of our heroes dressed as imperials
it feels like they're the enemy mando is
able to fight off a large portion of
these pirates in a scene that felt
reminiscent to
indiana jones in the last crusade but
soon they're overwhelmed but saved in
the nick of time by imperial tie
fighters i guess we've never really been
more happy to see tie fighters we even
get a look at these beige colored
troopers known as shore troopers which
are more adapted for coastal defense and
i guess it kind of makes sense they're
here because the whole refinery is
basically a giant dam
mando and mayfield are treated like
heroes as they arrive at the base
it just goes to show that what's
considered a hero is determined by what
side you're on
in the base they find the terminal which
is conveniently located in the mess hall
for some reason but mayfield says he
can't go in there because his former
superior a man by the name of valen
hesse
would recognize him it's no coincidence
that his last name
hess is named after one of nazi
germany's biggest war criminals
rudolph hess both these men were
responsible for countless atrocities
this new development requires mando
himself to take off his helmet and
complete the facial scan to upload moff
gideon's coordinates to his data stick
something he's able to do but attracts
the attention of
hess mayfield comes to the rescue with
the genius excuse that the reason
mando didn't respond to hess was his
hearing went after his transport ship
lost
pressure on tanab in the original
storyline for the movie solo
tanem was supposed to be featured and
depicted as a jungle planet but that
didn't pan out
hess sits them down for a celebratory
drink as their vessel was the only one
that day to make it back in one piece
meanwhile cara and fenik scope out the
exterior guards to prepare for boba
fett's arrival the friendly drink
doesn't go nearly to plan as mayfield
inquires about hess's command of
operation
cinder on vernon khan an operation he
was a part of which saw
ten thousand men sacrifice for the quote
good of the empire
it took place weeks following the battle
of endor a plan put in place by
palpatine himself valance is by creating
havoc people will flock to the empire
once again
everybody thinks they want freedom
but what they really want is order
perhaps this is a nod to the first order
and its eventual ascension to power
mayfield is so infuriated by hess he
shoots him and he and mendo fight for
their lives shooting their way out of
yet
another sticky situation with cara and
fenec taking care of the guards outside
boba is clear to rescue the two men
safely getting them out with the
coordinates from off gideon
intact on their way out mayfeld puts his
imperial sharpshooter skills to the test
blasting a tank of rydonium destroying
the facility
in some ways it's showing off to mando
who in chapter 6 questioned mayfeld's
shooting skills
former imperial sharpshooter that's not
saying much
i wasn't a stormtrooper wise ass and it
wouldn't be an episode of the
mandalorian without one final threat to
their escape as two tie fighters chase
after them in a throwback to attack of
the clones where
jango fett unleashes a seismic charge in
the asteroid field
boba does the same completely oblitering
the two fighters
back to safety mayfield is ready to go
back to the scrap heap but mando and
kara give him his freedom
opting to tell the authorities that
prisoner 34667
died on morak with the coordinates now
collected mando can turn his sights on
moff gideon and the child he sends a
warning message to moff which is
basically the
dialogue from taken i will find you
and i will kill you actually mando's
dialogue here is almost the exact same
dialogue used by moff gideon in season
one
you may think you have some idea what
you are in possession of
but you do not you may think you have
some idea of what you are in possession
of
but you do not the only difference here
is that moff refers to grogu as
it and mando refers to him as he really
showing how mando views him as a person
while moff views him as an
object to be owned the only question
that remains here is how
mando plans to infiltrate an entire
imperial cruiser
and retrieve moff's most prized
possession will we see moth finally use
his dark saber and will
other characters like ahsoka and bokutan
make an appearance
will kara doon use her links with the
new republic to call on additional
firepower to take out the imperials
whatever happens the season finale is
shaping up to be super epic
and if everything works out i'll be able
to cover it next week thanks for
watching everyone
please make sure to like and subscribe
and follow me on twitter and instagram
at think story yt until next time
remember
i have spoken